Richard was telling me about a new
horror film that he went to see he in
fact did the kickstarter campaign for it
he the movie is called terrifier so what
is that Richard that you're holding up a
mask of some sort that is Art the clown
the uh star of terrifier two who I'm a
massive fan of Richard is such a fan of
the movie terrifier they were thinking
about making a terror Fire 2 horror film
and he what they asked for money from
the audience and you you donated 25
bucks right yeah yeah I wanted to see it
happen because the first terrifier like
when you're an adult it's rare to get
scared or freaked out by a horror movie
that is one of two movies as an adult
that has scared the [ __ ] out of me and
it has a scene in it that is so goddamn
gruesome it might be the grossest scene
of all time of any movie I'm not a
horror I mean you know a horror
Aficionado like you are but a killer
clown very original I mean you would
come up you would think that that that's
why art the clown is so great you'd
think well it's been done a million
times no he is the scariest clown ever
he doesn't talk but his face and his
emotions and movements are so goddamn
scary is Art the clown a human being or
is he some other worldly kind of dude
well see that's what that's what makes a
perfect horror movie to me that's why I
love the original Halloween so much
because you think he's a human being
right and then he turns out to be more
than just a human being and I I'm I
could cry thinking about that I [ __ ]
love that I love when a movie takes you
somewhere that you're not expecting so
listen to this I gotta play this for you
this is the news reports or terrifier
too they say this movie terrifier too is
so grotesque
well not bam but but people are what are
they they're throwing up and what else
are they doing they're passing anything
out I saw people leave I saw terrifier
too last night and people left
it made me so happy I'm like oh God I
love this movie so much well why are
they leaving in other words do they walk
into the theater ex I mean they know
what terrifier is why would they leave
and they you know maybe maybe they're
thinking it's a more mainstream stream
type of horror movie this is not
mainstream if you're looking for you
know I don't know just like a cut
run-of-the-mill horror movie that's not
what this is here's the news reports you
gotta love this well vomit bags are
being passed out to customers lining up
to see terrifier two the movie is so
disturbing that some fans have been
fainting and even vomiting in the middle
of the theater another said the guy
behind me passed out cold and crashed
into my chair and I've heard a guy
puking hard and loud in the bathroom
another said terrifier 2 is so gory I
puked in my popcorn people did leave
like I saw people leaving during it it
was great and it's funny because I snuck
in a couple pumpkin beers during the
movie too and uh so I had to pee in the
middle of it and I went into the movie
theater bathroom and it was one of the
creepiest bathrooms I've ever been in
and it really I was scared being in
there the stall door was closed I didn't
want to open it because I was like maybe
aren't the Clown's in there so I used
the urinal but the urinal was stopped up
and it was literally pissed up to the
rim of the urine
the movie theater is that I mean my God
it's horrible I mean it was an older
movie theater but to me that kind of
added to the Ambiance but did you piss
in the urinal anyway even though it was
almost done it was splashing everywhere
and a little spilling on the floor I
stood way back that's Fred that's the
greatest song ever that you're playing
right now that is my favorite song of
all time you seem to be getting
emotional as this song is playing I do
it means so much touched me John
Carpenter I grew up on his movies my
parents used to take that my parents
took me to see John Carpenter's The
Thing at the drive-in while I was eight
and it [ __ ] blew my blew my mind and
made me a lifelong horror fan and made
me this is why I cry that's why I'm so
passionate this song Let's listen and
watch who cried and endlessly
entertaining it's beautiful
it's beautiful
[Music]
thank you